bonjour à tous alors aujourd'hui une
vidéo un petit peu particulière à
l'occasion du premier anniversaire de la
chaîne puisque le 11 avril ça fera très
exactement un an que la chaîne du
précepteur énoncés alors alors je vous
parle vous êtes déjà plus de 16 mille
abonnés sur cette chaîne
donc je tiens à vous remercier du fond
du coeur merci pour votre fidélité
merci pour votre soutien et je me suis
dit que un an
ben c'était peut-être le bon moment pour
sortir une vidéo un petit peu non
conventionnelles par rapport à ce que
j'ai l'habitude de proposer sur ma
chaîne en l'occurrence une vidéo dans
laquelle je voudrais un petit peu parlé
de ma personne plus exactement de mon
parcours et de mon rapport au travail de
mon expérience du travail puisqu'on est
sur une chaîne de pédagogie dans
laquelle j'essaie de valoriser la notion
de travail
je pense que ça peut vous donner des
clés de compréhension de ce que je
propose sur ma chaîne si vous connaissez
un petit peu plus mon parcours mon
parcours personnel donc je vais me
prêter à cet exercice assez inhabituel
dans lequel pour tout vous dire je ne
suis pas spécialement à l'aise qui est
de vous parler de moi tout simplement en
fait mais dans un but bien précis qui
est de vous expliciter ma conception du
travail
je vais partir de mes 18 ans l'âge
auquel j'ai obtenu mon bac donc j'ai
fait ma scolarité au lycée henri iv à
béziers j'ai obtenu mon bac à 18 en 2004
et c'est un bac littéraire et après ce
bac donc j'ai démarré mes études études
de philosophie à montpellier et c'est
aussi l'année où j'ai commencé à
travailler alors mon premier travail mon
premier job d'été comme on dit c'était
déménageurs j'ai commencé par faire des
déménagements
quand j'avais 18 ans un petit peu de
manière accidentelle c'est à dire qu'en
fait je traînais avec un vieil ami que
je connais depuis la maternelle
et puis en fait il me dit un jour qu'il
décide d'aller s'inscrire dans une
agence d'intérim pour gagner un petit
peu d'argent pendant l'été et à ce
moment là je ne savais même pas ce que
c'était l'intérim
pour tout vous dire je partais de loin
et je me suis dit bah écoutes je vais
t'accompagner et puis tu veux en
profiter pour m'inscrire moi aussi
résultat des courses on se retrouve à
s'inscrire dans une agence d'intérim
dans plusieurs agences d'intérim et puis
mon était ce parce je continue un petit
peu a profité de la plage
et puis un beau matin alors que j'étais
en train de dormir je reçois un coup de
téléphone
c'est l agence d'intérim qui m'appelait
pour me dire on a une mission à vous
proposer
alors à l'époque pour moi une mission
c'était une mission d'agent secret je me
suis dit ils m'ont pris pour james bond
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
est en fait non une mission c'est tout
simplement le nom qu'on donne à un
emploi temporaire en intérim et donc
comme à cette époque là je n'avais aucun
diplôme
à part le bac bien sûr ils m'ont proposé
des métiers manuels donc le premier le
premier emploi que j'occupais c'était
déménageurs à ce moment là je suis sorti
de mon lit en précipitation je me suis
habillé j'ai pris le bus et je me suis
rendu directement à l'adresse où avait
lieu le déménagement je me suis présenté
et puis j'ai fait ma première journée de
travail
donc on était je crois qu'on était en
juillet ou en août 2004 je savais que
j'allais faire des études de philosophie
à la rentrée de septembre
et j'étais très à l'aise dans ce domaine
là c'est à dire que j'ai toujours aimé
réfléchir nous poser des problèmes
tenter de les résoudre
d'ailleurs j'aime et autant la
philosophie que les mathématiques parce
que les mathématiques ça reste de la
résolution de problèmes et pour autant
je n'ai jamais eu de rejet vis-à-vis des
activités manuelles
j'ai toujours été très sportif mon
modèle quand j'étais enfant c'était ses
terres au pire c'était sylvester
stallone j'adorais dragon ball j'adorais
les films d'action j'adorais le sport la
boxe la musculation et pour moi c'était
totalement stupide totalement inepte de
séparer le corps et l'esprit
le travail manuel ne m'a jamais fait
peur et quand j'ai j'ai expérimenté donc
le travail manuel
par cet emploi de déménageur bien en
fait je me suis rendu compte que j'étais
bon j'ai reçu des félicitations de la
part de mes collègues de travail de la
part du patron de l'entreprise dans
laquelle j'ai été envoyé et donc cette
agence d'intérim a eu de très bons
retours de mon travail
et finalement je me suis aperçu à ce
moment là que
j'étais capable par mon travail et par
une certaine exigence de qualité dans
mon travail j'étais capable d'obtenir
une forme de reconnaissance que je ne
soupçonnais pas en fait parce que
j'étais surtout à l'époque
reconnu pour mes bons résultats
scolaires et ça c'est quelque chose que
j'ai vécue de manière très valorisante
lorsqu'on a 18 ans qu'on commence à
travailler de ses mains qu'on touche son
premier salaire et qu'en plus de ça on
reçoit des félicitations
je peux vous dire que c'est très
structurant en fait c'est très
valorisant pour les styles de soi et
c'est à ce moment là qu'on commence à se
sentir devenir adulte c'est vraiment un
rite initiatique et c'est pour ça que si
vous avez des enfants qui sont en âge de
travailler on est en âge de travailler à
partir de 16 ans au en france
aujourd'hui
mais moi je vous encourage à aller
mettre au travail en fait sans forcément
leur demander leur avis tout simplement
leurs 10 ans dorénavant si tu veut de
l'argent de poche et bien cet argent de
poche tu vas aller le gagner toi-même
par le travail de terrain par la sueur
de ton front et je peux vous assurer que
en faisant ça vous allez leur rendre un
très grand service parce que vous allez
leur donner la possibilité d'être fiers
d'eux-mêmes de gagner une confiance en
soi qu'on ne peut pas obtenir autrement
j'ai donc fais ma mission pendant
quelques semaines en tant que déménageur
et puis à la fin de l'été au mois d'août
je reçois une nouvelle proposition de
mon agence d'intérim et cette fois-ci
s'agissait de travailler dans une grande
surface
le l'enseigne auchan pour ne pas la
nommer
l'hypermarché auchan à à béziers est
donc là on me propose une mission d'une
semaine avec pour horaire minuit 9
heures du matin je dis pas de problème
pas de problème je prends j'avais déjà
mis un pied dans le travail je peux vous
dire que dès les nageurs en plein été
dans le sud de la france
vous le sentez pas c'est si vous êtes
capable de faire ça vous êtes capable de
travailler dans un magasin climatisés
quand bien même ce serait de minuit à 9
heures du matin il n'y a pas de problème
donc je commence ce nouvel emploi
et puis là encore
je fais du bon travail c'est à dire que
quand j'arrive dans l'entreprise
j'arrive avec une forme d'humilité même
j'étais assez intimidant pour tout vous
dire c'est à dire qu'à 18 ans ont fait
pas on fais pas l'fou quand on arrive
dans une grande entreprise qui
fonctionne avec plus de 250 employés
avec des gens qui sont hyper rodez qui
ont un sens de l'organisation à toute
épreuve
je peux vous dire que vous avez intérêt
à être observateur vous avez intérêt à
être attentif à l'écouté des consignes
des directives et que là encore si vous
faites du mauvais boulot
vous pouvez être sûr qu'une fois que
votre chef aura signé le relevés
d'heures on vous rappellera pas donc
vous êtes obligé de vous accrochez vous
êtes obligé de montrer que vous en
voulez et là encore si vous faites du
bon boulot et on sera très heureux de
vous garder mes employeurs ont été
satisfaits du travail que j'ai fait et
c'est là que j'ai commencé vraiment à
rentrer dans la machine en me disant on
est capable finalement quand on s'en
donne les moyens quand on a suffisamment
de volonté on est capable d'obtenir
cette reconnaissance professionnelle
dont on nous dit souvent qu'elle dépend
en fait du bon vouloir de l'employeur du
bon vouloir du patron c'est vrai dans
certains cas mais dans ce qui est
travail manuel manutentionnaires je peux
vous dire que c'est vraiment au mérite
c'est vraiment à l'effort que ça se joue
et en tout cas c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé pour moi et donc c'est comme
ça que j'ai entamé mon expérience du
travail du travail manuel l'été se
termine je veux inscrire à la fac de
lettres de montpellier
l'université paul valéry en philosophie
et j'alterne entre des moments où je
vais à la fac alors j'habitais encore à
béziers du coup je prenais le train tous
les matins jusqu'à montpellier il ya à
peu près 70 km donc en tout j'en avais
pour une heure de trajet à partir du
moment où où je partais de la gare de
béziers au moment où j'arrivais à la fac
il s'est écoulé à peu près une heure
donc j'avais une heure de trajet aller
et retour je passais ma journée à la fac
je suivais mes cours enfin ma journée
c'est une façon de parler parce que je
peux vous dire que licence de
philosophie et licence universitaire en
général vous n'avez pas 40 heures de
cours par semaine
on avait à peu près une vingtaine
d'heures de cours grand maximum
et donc c'était pas disons s'était pas
d'une d'un poids totalement écrasant
c'était totalement supportable et donc
je me suis inscrit dans une espèce de
routine où je me levais le matin je
prenais mon train j'allais à la fac je
rentrais le soir et le soir et bien
j'allais travailler à auchan je faisais
mes heures je gagner un petit peu
d'argent comme ça et je me suis rendu
compte qu'en fait il était totale
totalement possible dès l'âge de 18 ans
de prendre son indépendance financière
à condition de s'en donner les moyens
alors j'étais boursiers à l'université
c'est à dire que je toucher une
allocation d'environ 350 euros par mois
si je me souviens bien
donc la bourse est toujours calculé sur
les revenus des parents et comme mes
parents n'étaient pas imposables
le gagnant assez peu d'argent j'ai
bénéficié de cette bourse universitaire
et comme je n'avais pas de logements
universitaires j'habitais encore chez
mes parents pendant ma première année de
fac
j'avais pas de loyer à payer du coup je
gagnais à peu près 4 500 euros par mon
travail plus 350 euros de bourse et je
payais je crois 90 euros par mois pour
le train donc au final je pouvais me
dégager un petit salaire qui me
permettait qui me permettait finalement
de prendre en charge mes propres
dépenses j'étais animé d'un désir
vraiment vraiment vif vraiment profond
de prendre cette indépendance
ça a toujours été dans l'anr de
fonctionner en fait j'ai toujours mis un
point d'honneur à ne pas dépendre des
autres à ne pas dépendre d'eux delà de
la charité pour apprendre et un grand
mot des autres et c'est pour ça que j'ai
toujours travaillé depuis mes 18 ans et
que je n'ai jamais eu finalement à me
laisser porter par ce que j'avais des
parents qui m'aurait payer un
appartement ou qui auraient payé mes
études ou qui m'aurait donné de l'argent
de poche
je trouve ça très bien que des parents
puissent aider leurs enfants à suivre
leurs études dans de bonnes conditions
mais il ya un revers de la médaille
c'est que quand on fait ça et bien
l'enfant qui devient adulte finalement
devient adulte par l'âge mais ne devient
pas adulte par le vécu ne devient pas
adulte par la pratique et devenir adulte
c'est travailler c'est gagner son argent
c'est se lever le matin en se disant que
si on ne se lève pas on sera pas payé et
si on n'est pas payé on peut pas bouffer
moi je dis souvent que la réalité c'est
ce qu'on assume et on ne peut pas ne pas
l'assumer la réalité parce qu'en fait on
aura beau dire tout ce qu'on voudra si
on a rien dans le frigo on peut rien
faire voyez donc à partir de là il n'y a
pas cinquante solutions c'est soit on se
démerde pour survivre ou soit on trouve
d'autres solutions mais généralement ces
solutions là ne sont pas pérennes
pendant des années j'ai suivi ce rythme
au point que la plupart de mes collègues
de travail en fait ne savais même pas
que j'étais étudiant il pensait que
j'étais un employé un salarié comme à
plein temps parce que le samedi le
vendredi le samedi je passais tellement
d'heures dans l'entreprise que je
croisais je connaissais tout le
personnel et certains ne se rendent même
pas compte que la semaine j'étais pas là
donc c'était assez drôle c'était assez
drôle et puis c'était assez là aussi
c'était assez valorisant de se
considérer comme un membre à part
entière d'une équipe parce que ce qu'il
faut pas oublier c'est que quand vous
travaillez dans une grande entreprise
eh bien vous créer des relations vous
créez même d amitié avec vos collègues
de travail et vous apprenez à découvrir
d'autres manières de penser que la vôtre
à 18 ans on connaît pas grand chose de
la vie est quand vous passez 20 minutes
de pause abord votre café à fumer votre
cigarette avec une caissière qui est là
depuis 20 ans ou avec un employé qui est
là depuis trente ans et qui vous
racontent un petit peu sa vie mais je
peux vous dire que ça vous instruis vous
apprenez beaucoup de choses et à ce
moment là vous voyez autrement ce que
vous apprenez quand vous êtes à la fac
et moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que quand j'étais à la fac fac de philo
à montpellier les étudiants avec qui
j'étais en cours
je les avait en horreur il m'a supporté
au plus haut point parce que j'entendais
des gamins de 20 ans me parler de
révolution me parler de prolétariat me
parler de justice des mots plein la
gueule mais sans aucune consistance des
mots creux des coquilles vides
et je me disais mais ces personnes là si
on les met dans les conditions de
travail qui étaient les miennes à
l'époque elle ne tiendrait même pas une
semaine des personnes qui savaient tout
mieux que tout le monde qui avait tout
fait avait tout compris et mépris un
mépris social inconscient in assumer
mais débordant c'est à dire que les le
prolétariat pour eux c'était un concept
mais derrière ce concept a eu ce qu'il
voyait c'était la populace
c'était la plèbe c'était les gens qui
vont au bistrot pour jouer au pmu
il y avait beaucoup de mépris en fait
dans ses paroles comme par exemple
lorsqu'on entend dire ça c'est le
discours café du commerce discours café
du commerce c'est à dire ça c'est ça
c'est les prolos alcoolo qui parle comme
ça voyez le genre d'expressions qu'on
entend problème c'est que ces prolos
pour les avoir côtoyés pendant dix ans
parce que j'ai travaillé en entreprise
pendant dix ans et je peux vous dire que
il dégage infiniment plus de sagesse il
dégage infiniment plus de bon sens et de
compréhension du réel que des petits
contes 20 ans qui ont fait 6 mois de
d'études et qui pensent tout savoir et
tout connaître
donc je vous passe certaines situations
et certains clash que j'ai pu avoir avec
des étudiants je vous en parlerai
peut-être dans une autre vidéo si jamais
vous en faites la demande
mais en attendant j'ai tiré toutes mes
études en faisant voilà ce en adoptant
ce schéma la fac la semaine le travail
le week-end les vacances vacances
scolaires c'est à dire que voilà pour
beaucoup de gens être étudiant c'est
être en vacances permanentes mais je
peux vous assurer que pendant toutes mes
années de fac j'ai pas eu une semaine de
vacances parce que lorsque j'avais des
vacances scolaires j'allais travailler à
plein temps pendant l'été je travaillais
à plein temps de fin mai parce que les
cours finissent et fin mai jusqu'à fin
septembre
ça m'est même arrivé de de continuer à
travailler à plein temps alors que les
cours avaient déjà repris donc il y
avait des cours auquel n'assistait pas
je demandais à mes collègues de deux
facs d'enregistrer le court pour que je
puisse le réécouter dans la voiture
pour pouvoir passer mon partiel en fin
de semestre voyez alors évidemment je
suis pas en train de faire du
misérabilisme vous entendez bien dans ma
manière de de vous raconter mon histoire
que il ya aucun ressentiment au
contraire en fait je me dis que ça a été
une chance a posteriori ça a été une
chance de vivre cette vie de travail de
vivre cette vie de contraintes qui m'a
mis du plomb dans la tête et qui m'a
fait comprendre à quel point le travail
était un outil d'émancipation personnel
de développement personnel dans le sens
noble du terme
oui le travail est une contrainte le
travail est une obligation
je suis assez d'accord avec ceux qui
disent que le but ultime de la vie c'est
de pouvoir arrêter de travailler alors
plus exactement je dirais que c'est de
pouvoir choisir son travail en réalité
parce que j'en ai parlé dans un live que
j'ai fait récemment ma définition de la
réussite c'est vivre de sa passion
c'est réussir à faire coïncider son
désir et la contrainte la contrainte du
travail la contrainte de se nourrir avec
l'accomplissement de soi par sa passion
mais je maintiens que le travail reste
la meilleure école de la vie et cette
école là j'y suis resté pendant dix ans
alors comment ça s'est passé bien au
bout de ma première année j'ai obtenu ma
première année de licence et pendant
l'été qui a suivi j'ai travaillé à
auchan à béziers pendant pendant cinq
mois d'affilée à plein temps et là j'ai
rencontré j'ai rencontré une demoiselle
qui est devenue ma petite amie qui elle
aussi travailler en même temps qu'elle
faisait ses études ses études de
biologie et à la rentrée eh bien elle
faisait ses études comme moi à
montpellier on s'est assez rapidement
installé sous le même toit et on a vécu
ensemble pendant six ans et demi six ans
et demi pendant lesquels pendant mes
études parce que je suis allé jusqu'au
niveau doctorat j'ai suivi donc ma
licence mon master le début de mon
doctorat tout en continuant à travailler
en parallèle dans cette même entreprise
il était je travaille de nuit je
travaillais
de trois heures à 11 heures du matin
donc je peux vous dire que les premières
fois ça fait drôle de se lever à 2
heures du matin l'heure à laquelle je me
couchais habituellement là là on se lève
à 2 heures du matin je peux vous dire
que votre corps comprend pas ce qui se
passe et je peux vous assurer que quand
vous avez fait cinq ans six ans de
travail de nuit que vous entendez des
gens se plaindre parce qu'ils ont 18
heures de cours par semaine ça vous fait
rigoler ça vous fait rigoler en fait non
ça vous énerve ça vous met en colère et
vous avez juste envie de le retourner
une bonne tarte dans la tronche pour
leur faire comprendre la chance qu'ils
ont la chance dont ils n'ont pas
conscience en fait et c'est ça le drame
en fait c'est que quelqu'un qui grandit
sans avoir une expérience du travail
pénibles ne sais pas en fait ce que
c'est que le travail est sacrée des
individus non seulement un conscient de
la réalité du travail mais ça crée des
individus capricieux prétentieux part et
ceux pour qui le moindre effort est vécu
comme quelque chose d'insupportable et
d'insoutenables sacré des personnes qui
n'ont pas d'auto discipline
j'ai souvent dit que le service
militaire est quelque chose à quoi
j'étais content de pouvoir échapper et
avec le recul je me dis que le service
militaire est quelque chose qui aurait
pu accélérer ce processus d'auto
discipline que j'ai acquis par le
travail parce que la contrainte physique
c'est le meilleur moyen d'acquérir
l'autodiscipline l'autodiscipline c'est
ce qui vous permet de vous fixer des
objectifs et de les tenir
c'est à dire que c'est bien beau d'avoir
des projets c'est bien beau d'avoir des
rêves mais ses rêves sont voués à ne
rester que des chimères
tant qu'on ne met pas en oeuvre les
moyens de les atteindre et pendant des
années j'ai grandi avec l'idée qu' il
fallait avoir des rêves il fallait avoir
des perspectives d espoir est que
c'était ça le moteur de la vie mais en
fait c'est pas ça le moteur de la vie le
moteur de la vie
ce sont tous les rituels qu'on met en
place pour atteindre ses objectifs
parce qu'il n'ya rien de plus gratifiant
il ya rien de plus satisfaisant que
d'atteindre un objectif qu'on sait fille
et cet objectif peut être totalement
modeste ça peut être un objectif qui
paraît ridicule pour n'importe qui mais
qui aura du sens à nos yeux et à partir
du moment où ça a du sens à nos yeux
à partir du moment où ça une valeur eh
bien ça nous fait grandir
ça donne du sens à notre vie ça donne du
sens à ce qu'on fait c'est ça qui fait
que vous allez pouvoir vous lever de
votre lit le matin même si les deux
heures du matin
même si vous avez dormi une heure et
demi dans la nuit mais c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave parce que vous savez que
au bout de cet effort il y à la
concrétisation de votre projet et ça
c'est surpuissant
c'est pour ça que je dis à tous mes
élèves qui ont qui ont du mal à savoir
comment s'orienter à savoir ce qu'ils
veulent faire dans la vie jordi
simplement pense à ceux qui te fait te
levais le matin pense à ce qui te donne
de l'énergie
quand tu fais telle ou telle chose et
dis toi que c'est la seule chose qui
compte
le reste n'existe pas le reste n'a pas
d'importance peu importe ce que les gens
vous diront peu importe que les gens
essaient de vous décourager de vous
démobilisez personnellement c'est ce qui
m'est arrivé quand j'ai commencé à dire
à mon entourage
à 18 ans je vais m'inscrire à la fac je
vais avoir un travail de nuit à temps
partiel je vais passer mon permis je
vais prendre le train tous les matins
pour aller à la fac
les gens me regardent en rigolant me
disant mais tu vas jamais dire il le
disait avec une attention qui n'était
pas du tout malveillantes
il le disait comme ils le pensaient si
vous voulez moi je recevais ça comme
comme des injures ça sous-entend des
étais pas capable de le faire et ça
c'était presque un carburant un
stimulant pour moi
dans tous les cas je savais que c'était
pas ça qui allait m'empêcher de le faire
parce que je l'avais décidé et parce
qu'à partir du moment où on prend une
décision on peut dire tout ce qu'on
voudra autour de nous peu importe ça
compte pas on ne fait que ce qu'on a
décidé de faire et ça sert à rien de
forcer les gens ou de vouloir forcer les
gens à faire ce qu'ils n'ont pas décidé
de faire encourager les gens à faire ce
qu'ils ont décidé de faire et si ce
qu'ils ont décidé échoue et bien au
moins vous n'aurez pas contribuer à cet
échec
dans tous les cas dites vous bien une
chose c'est que si on fait une erreur
cette erreur nous servira on doit aller
au bout de nos erreurs
c'est pas grave de faire des erreurs
mais le tout c'est de laisser la
personne faire des erreurs avec
bienveillance sans chercher à infléchir
sa décision
laisser les gens faire dites vous bien
une chose c'est que si vous avez une
conscience c'est que les autres ont une
conscience également
et quand les gens vous disent qu'ils
vont faire quelque chose dites vous bien
que illusion réfléchi arrêtez de vouloir
expliquer aux gens ce qu'ils doivent
penser ou comment il doit vivre ça ne
marche pas et tout ce qui risque de vous
arriver c'est que cette personne va vous
démentir cette personne va vous prouver
que vous avez eu tort
accompagner les gens dans leurs projets
accompagner les gens dans leur décision
et vous verrez que vous n'aurez qu'à
vous en féliciter je ferme la parenthèse
quand toutes ces personnes ont alors
j'allais dire ont essayé de me dissuader
c'est pas la réalité elles n'ont pas
essayé de me dissuader mais en tout cas
quand elles m'ont fait part de leur
point de vue par rapport à ça ça ne m'a
pas du tout fait changer d'avis sur ce
que je devais faire
j'ai continué à suivre ma route j'ai
continué à faire ce que je croyais être
juste et au final je n'ai eu là encore
qu'à m'en réjouis et je n'ai eu que de
la gratification par rapport à ça parce
que ça m'a permis d'évoluer
ça m'a permis de grandir de devenir
adulte beaucoup plus vite que si j'avais
simplement suivi mes études financées
par papa maman je peux vous dire que
quand on paye de sa poche ses premières
vacances sont son premier voyage avec sa
petite amie ou
on est obligé de faire attention à ce
qu'on va dépenser on est obligé de
regarder les bonnes affaires pour
prendre son billet train voyez tout ce
ce genre de petites choses qui font en
fait la réalité de la vie d'un
travailleur
tous ces petits détails qui font que on
est obligé d'être conscient des choses
on est obligé de savoir comment les
choses se passent pour s'y adapter
parce que on peut pas faire ce qu'on
veut quand notre compte on est dans
cette situation
je dis souvent les gens pauvres les
travailleurs pauvres ne sont pas plus
vertueux que les autres mais ils ont la
vertu de la contrainte la vertu de la
contrainte c'est la vertu qu'on acquiert
par la contrainte et le bon sens le bon
sens populaire le bon sens cette
expression que beaucoup de gens aiment
dénigrer c'est ça le bon sens c'est de
dire on ne peut pas tout faire on ne
peut pas faire tout et n'importe quoi on
est obligé de prendre en compte les
répercussions de nos actes de nos
décisions sur notre vie et le travail
permet de développer une conscience
aiguë des conséquences de nos actes des
conséquences de nos choix et ça permet
d'avoir une compréhension du monde qu'on
ne trouve pas dans les livres ça ça
développe un rapport au travail très
spécial et c'est ce rapport au travail
que j'ai qui a ses avantages mais qui a
aussi ses inconvénients
je suis quelqu'un de très
perfectionniste je suis quelqu'un qui
n'aime pas qui ne supportent pas le
travail bâclé le travail mal fait je
déteste l'idée de faire quelque chose
simplement pour le faire pour moi une
chose si je la fais je veux qu'elle soit
bien fait ça peut produire certains
blocages c'est à dire par exemple que la
actuellement la vidéo que c'est en train
de tourner depuis le début j'ai cette
petite gêne de me dire que je n'ai pas
préparé cette vidéo donc je sais que je
ne serai pas totalement satisfait et ça
m'emmerde de mettre en ligne sur la
chaîne youtube une vidéo dont je ne
serai pas totalement satisfait mais
j'apprends je travaille sur moi
justement
j'apprends aussi à accepter
l'imperfection parce que
lorsqu on se fixe des objectifs
inatteignables c'est le meilleur moyen
d'être dans une frustration et dans une
immobilité permanente au bout d'un
moment il faut accepter les défauts faut
accepter l'imperfection
il faut accepter qu'on puisse trouver
que ce qu'on a fait c'est de la merde
c'est bon signe ça veut dire que on a
des axes de progression ça veut dire
qu'on évolue la plupart des choses que
j'ai pu faire jusqu'à aujourd'hui quand
je me retourne dessus je me dis c'était
nul
mais en fait c'était pas nul c'était pas
nul parce que c'est ce qui m'a permis de
progresser d'évoluer dans le bon sens il
est certain que tout ce que j'ai fait
jusqu'à présent m'a conduit à ce que je
suis aujourd'hui et sans aller jusqu'à
dire que je suis fier de moi fier de ce
que je fais je dirais en tout cas que je
n'en ai pas honte que je les assume que
je le revendique et et après tout on à
part on n'a pas à à s'auto dénigrer on
n'a pas à considérer que ce qu'on fait
c'est nul
si on ne pense pas j'ai la conviction
que le travail que je produis à travers
cette chaîne youtube le précepteur
j'ai l'intimé conviction que ce travail
est utile
d'un autre côté à chaque fois que je
revois une des vidéos que j'ai publié
sur la chaîne je vois tout ce qui ne va
pas je m'en veux ça me dérange mais je
me dis dans la balance il ya plus de
positif que de négatif
et quand je vois vos commentaires quand
je vois les pouces en l'air que vous
pouvez me laisser sur mes vidéos
généralement j'ai à peu près 90% de
pouce en l'air sur mes vidéos
à ce moment là je veux dit charles
détends toi regarde et vois que ton
travail
il est apprécié il est estimé et ça
suffit ne cherche pas à te fixer des
objectifs inatteignables
parce que c'est le meilleur moyen de
souffrir c'est le meilleur moyen d'être
malheureux aujourd'hui j'ai pris la
décision d'enregistrer une vidéo
beaucoup plus personnel que mes vidéos
habituel parce que
étant donné que mon domaine c'est la
pédagogie ben faut savoir que l'acte de
transmission ce qui est selon moi une
assez bonne définition de ce qu'on fait
dans la pédagogie
l'acte de transmission ça suppose un
lien de proximité
ça suppose un lien affectif avec la
personne qui est en face de nous et au
bout d'un moment je ne peux pas me
présenter à vous sur une chaîne de
pédagogie sans vous dévoiler une partie
de ce que je suis une partie de ma
personne et même si ça me met un petit
peu mal mal à l'aise de vous parler de
moi j'estime que c'est quelque chose que
je vous dois
et j'espère qu'en faisant ça mais vous
allez comprendre
un petit peu mieux peut-être le sens de
ma démarche
le sens de ma démarche c'est de vous
dire vous avez entre vos mains un
potentiel que vous ne soupçonnez même
pas chaque personne avec laquelle vous
interagissez vous pouvez éveillé en elle
des choses extraordinaires
j'ai rencontré énormément de personnes
tout au long de ma vie qui m'ont fait
prendre conscience de certaines choses
qui m'ont donné envie de faire certaines
choses et je me dis que sans ces
rencontres je serai toujours le charles
de 18 ans qui découvre la vie je
n'aurais pas avancer je n'aurais pas
évolué et aujourd'hui je remercie du
plus profond de mon coeur
toutes les personnes dont j'ai croisé le
chemin et qui m'ont permis de me
remettre en cause qui m'ont permis de
mieux comprendre certaines choses qui
m'ont permis de mieux accepter certaines
choses
et parmi ces choses ce que je suis parce
qu'en fait toutes ces personnes m'ont
transmis quelque chose et la
transmission s'est pas seulement ce que
fait le professeur envers son élève
la transmission c'est tout ce qui se
passe entre vous et l'autre lorsque vous
interagissez de manière sincère et
lorsque j'ai de manière sincère ça veut
dire sans considérer l'autre comme un
concurrent un rival un ennemi potentiel
on peut ne pas faire confiance à tout le
monde
je le comprends très bien et je ne vais
pas chercher à vous convaincre du
contraire
mais par contre on peut donner à l'autre
le crédit de ses intentions et donner à
l'autre le crédit de ses intentions
c'est simplement se dire cette personne
qui est en face de moi
et bien si je fais bien les choses
je vais éveiller chez elle quelque chose
de bon quelque chose de bon pour elle
quelque chose de bon pour le groupe et
donc indirectement quelque chose de bon
pour moi aussi penser à ça vous avez ce
pouvoir magique d'interagir avec les
autres de manière à faire émerger le
meilleur en elle je ne dis pas que ce
que je fais sur ma chaîne youtube
consiste à faire émerger le meilleur qui
est en chacun d'entre vous mais je dis
simplement que c'est une petite pierre à
l'édifice dont j'espère qu'elle sera
peut-être une petite source
d'inspiration pour quelques internautes
j'ai toujours du mal à parler devant une
caméra
parce que pour moi c'est pas naturel de
parler à une machine
je vais essayer dorénavant de me dire
que je ne parle pas une caméra mais que
je parle à un être humain est cet être
humain je ne sais pas quel âge il a je
ne sais pas où ils habitent je ne sais
pas ce qu'il fait dans la vie mais je
sais que cet être humain
il a en lui quelque chose de bon que
j'ai le pouvoir des veillées
si je me prends bien et j'aimerais vous
proposer de faire la même chose et
j'aimerais vous vous demandez tout
simplement de garder ça à l'esprit
lorsque vous interagissez avec les
autres de garder ça à l'esprit lorsque
vous allez poster un commentaire de
garder ça à l'esprit lorsque vous allez
parler à votre enfant à votre frère à
votre soeur à votre conjoint à votre
conjointe à vos parents à vos voisins à
toutes les personnes que vous côtoyez en
vous disant que vous aussi vous avez ce
pouvoir de faire émerger le meilleur et
faire émerger le meilleur en l'autre
c'est un très bon moyen de faire émerger
le meilleur en soi et comme dirait
l'autre c'est tout le mal que je vous
souhaite